you know
for
marilyn
well they are
this is not there to inside
she would be a genocide throughout may
seek
to help you make the transition to on
it's a well-known fact that sergeants
knew more about religion anybody else
so it's a good idea to mister when your
sergeant talked
out your you've all heard the same
there's a right way
out wrong way
any army when
my job is to teach you the uh...
the army waiting to everything
including many things you've been doing
all your life
things that will help you and your
future jobs anymore i mean
things that might be called
strictly personal
it
were
memorable
marin
arun
ordering
or in
mingling with allot of things
if that were anyways there is the world
indeed each of you will have to be
wanted about decimal i did
the army insists on a high standard of
going to
this begins with a cane you give your
own money
after all a twenty fourteen inside the
uniform that really count
keep your leads j
they look metering yes dr
keep your under arms control
it's one of the ways to guard against
natural body odor
peter laufer shower at least
gay debating is a necessity the dig into
it when living in a close hoon
he won't be fleet won't to get one
munching the monies one line
don't risk offending levels
to be really cool is being cleaned from
this came out
what do you want yourself contained unit
be sure to wash out to stockings enjoy
under clothes every day
and put on it means that every day to
you
in addition to hang in there
men would mean group
one home milken ruin the total
impression
demand black
your head should be needed to mop note
to the show
but inappropriate blame
uniform in the car
it should not extend below the bottom
edge of the common
this obviously wanting
need to move in
known in the winds on the one thing
injured always tried to help them
do your best brush your hair once a day
and washing
pointed out that night if that's the way
to keep it looking
and don't violate one else's hairbrush
and home
they wouldn't hurt to knows it too
brushed your teeth after every meal
there's only one rightly to brush your
teeth
that's not it privately
brush with an up-and-down motion gently
massaging your guns while you clean your
teeth
that's more like private baking
you should have to toothbrushes
use them all to know
to do it in a plastic cup on your
monitor sir
by keeping your toothbrush is exposed to
the aid
then have a chance to drive op any germs
on them will die of natural death
wash your face a couple of times a day
washington post on it
gives you a little bit
like you'd put on your face in the
daytime is the army's business
you're not
my bedtime private baker to put on a
complicated makeup like that happened
but more important
wearing a lot of make up with a black
uniform is bad tapes
how to the next day parade no
all of the natural shape of your lips
and blah blah any excess let's stick
with the claims of jewish
another part of goodwill needed care if
you had a few days
people
and keeping a national so they don't
interfere with your work
if you're using your money
use a moderate or colorless one
way punish me
kindly anything that looks worse than it
should be o'connor
carrying a common dipstick movement
during the day
multipoint if rationing of your
appearance between classes
table always look mean
the well-dressed black is always ready
for inspection
stocking seen scraped
uniform press
brass polished incorrectly plates
handy
morning one-inch about the right
highbrow
not down on the moon
everything just dropped
but the home
can be spoiled by bad posture
and an off football
there are many different ways to work
isn't quality
waited for the appropriate the if
they've been gaby dot sloughed
the
brown and teenager waco but none of them
looks right or uses the muscles problem
there is only one comment wait awhile in
the wild
with head up displaying riding in the
and when you are posturing going feel
better and you look at it
and day
lacked the
and
k
marching to classes and even greater in
your future army assignments all your
life
the condition of your pain company
working hard and physical well-being
so it's important to take proper care of
them from the start
warmly
when you are clearly hurt you
group all over
and you're not much good for anything
that's why the army takes so much care
in fifteen your new shoes properly
but it's equally important
it s socks and stockings also be the
right size
they had to show what ought to know
they will make your pizza
and they may give you blisters
alternate among your shoes from one day
to the banks
so that they will get broken in
graduating pains
after they are broken and continue to
alternate they're wearing
and have randolph deals with pain
to avoid ingrown toenails train your
mail straight across
where your shower slickers to and from
the tree
he sure did drive carefully between your
toes after spending pork taking about
the shower
and watch for chronic skin between hippo
it may be the first sign of athlete's
foot
painful infection which
thrives in the warm down a rep swimming
pools and the tree
and can spread rapidly from one person
to another
do you think you have acne split
we'd like to meet platoon sergeant
immediately
when you go into town to buy your
problems
not good taste beyond god
get a plain black leather
unsuitable commercial design but closed
toe in kenya
he surely geo is at least
one of the house inches high
but not more than three inches high
the with these rules and mine
the redistrict any pair of plane hiking
you background promised offense
and expresses your individuality
fancy shoes do not belong with the
military uniform
the always inappropriate is this would
be
k
accorded hearing
and high level of energy
armenians are carefully planned to give
you a balanced diet is a proper wings
in the proper precautions
each day the army menu officer apparent
selection in the bottom
pastry incapable carbohydrates that give
you an answer
brilliant salads for minerals and
vitamins that build blood involved
bunker protein in fact that also give
you an answer
need updates for the protein that
develops muscle tone
starches like beans or potato
vegetables such as string beans
automated
and of course such staples of read email
all of these aren't necessary food
so take somebody everything that every
year
only dot weight and make sure you get a
variety of food
to maintain health and energy
this is the right way to go down the
line
and games
is the wrong way
second helpings of violence
but when you eat more food in your body
needs nobody goes on
and when you concentrate on high-calorie
foods to the exclusion of everything
else
the same thing
i'm gonna love
don't eat snacks between means
dispassionately not candy and scream
still doesn't
or other fattening sweets
it
big represent excess calories along with
about what you need
and what is already being provided in
the muscle
we're
one candy bar everyday
and putting extra ten to fifteen pounds
on you any year private baker